it has a hook on it so it can hook i can
hold my hand like that
and it can the end of it can hook around
i think this
finger
i remember it should feel like an
extension of my hand
schindler's list in schindler's list i
played
armond gert who was the commandant of a
nazi labor camp
in outside krakow in poland i hadn't
done i'd done maybe two
feature films before i remember being
struck by
stephen's extraordinary knowledge of the
technique of filmmaking which in my very
limited experience i hadn't experienced
anyone being so vocal about
lenses and how they're going to shoot
and we'll do it like this and put a
dolly down here
i mean and it was exciting because it
felt like someone was
unashamedly vocal about their process as
as it was happening and i remember he
said to me
i'm shooting this i've made no
storyboards i'm just shooting this
obviously he knew his script inside out
but he was allowing himself to be
inventive on the day
that's what he said he said you know
i've just directed jurassic park
everything's storyboarded to the nth
degree this is the opposite
and the energy of that oppositeness was
his
aliveness and it was you know he was
very vocal and
demanding a lot of the crew but it was
it was exciting i tried to do as much
research as i could and based on thomas
connealy's book schindler's
arc originally then it was called
schindler's list but
i mean the imperial war museum here in
london there's quite a lot of
documentation
about schindler and gert and i think
what i came away with this is the man
who
had a he drank a lot armon gert i think
he was uh
and he ate a lot the scene with ambeth
davids
playing helen here in the cellar
i would like so much to
reach out and touch you in your
loneliness
what that what would that be like i
wonder i mean
what would be wrong with that and i
realized that
you're not a person in the strictest
sense of the world but that was um
it's quite a challenging it's a
beautifully written scene i just
remember
the challenge of a man who's suddenly
finding
someone designated in his eyes as
unacceptable
he sees all that prejudice starts to
slightly crack
possibly because of he's allowing an
attraction or a desire
to come to the surface i mean it was
feels very human
the harry potter series i hadn't
invested time in reading the books
i knew there was a harry potter huge
thing happening but i hadn't
seen the earlier film so i i had no
sense
it was only when my sister who has
children
said don't you realize what they're
asking you to do is extraordinary and i
saw
and then i took it a bit more seriously
i wasn't that aware when it was first
proposed to me i
is this do i like this part what does it
involve you know
is it something i would enjoy playing
and i did in the end yeah you're a
full harry potter
and you will lose she describes the
voice
in a couple of places at least which was
a good
indicator of where to go and the snake
like
idea that jk rowling gives him as
someone but that he himself has
snake-like
elements to his movement silky smooth
silent with stuart craig who is the
production designer and his team we
discussed what the
wand would be it has a hook on it so it
can hook
i can hold my hand like that and it can
the end of it can hook around i think
this
finger so it can sort of i can almost
have the hand open so it would you think
it might fall off the hand but it
um i don't know i just enjoyed
the thing that could it could be light
in the hand i didn't i didn't have as
much prosthetic makeup as people think i
did
they removed my nose digitally later on
so i was covered in colored dots and
then i had to sit in front of cameras
and
every angle recorded and then for the
the digital expert mark coulier was the
makeup artist for me and his team
gave me a white pale pale sort of sickly
complexion but then they had these
sort of vein like paintwork which was
actually transfers
so they could have consistency so they
just
sponged the transfers onto my scalp and
face
to give this sort of slightly
translucent
vein like quality to the to my the
sickly pala
seen at the table when i talk about
muggles
to her the mixture of magical and muggle
blood
is not an abomination but something to
be encouraged
and then the snake comes up a lot and
that i love that see i think it's the
beginning of the first part of deathly
hallows
[Music]
[Music]
dinner
that was a great scene and i love
shooting the death duel
that was cool with daniel in the in the
big courtyard
that was epic
what's that like how do you get yourself
in that moment you know when you do you
visualize the blasts coming from your
wand
you just have to hate harry potter
there's a deep loathing
[Laughter]
i'll be i'd be pissed if they brought
back voldemort and didn't ask me
corey elena's sort of decision to
direct came indirectly
i was close to a great producer called
simon channing williams who
produced all mike lee films until sadly
he died he had a project
which he tried to make with me but it
didn't work
that initial process of script
conversations and some location scouts
and
starting to put on the hat of a director
that gave me a kind of confidence
to reach into an idea in my back pocket
which i had had
if i ever would direct it would be this
that shakespeare played corey elaine's
which is
not often done not i wouldn't say it's
one of his most popular plays
the very antagonistic confrontational
elitist
central protagonist but fascinating play
about politics and
power and people
[Applause]
with corey elena's i definitely
reference basler as romeo and juliet
as a very bold exciting modernization
using shakespeare's text but committing
to a modern
world i want desperate audiences to feel
that
whatever the language might be doing
that the emotions and the actions and
the motivations
are ones we carry in us today i will
fight
against my country
and then men die but it was a it was a
tricky sell
my first film obviously easily labeled
as
vanity project for this actor and all
that stuff it was scary
directing myself the challenge was i
mustn't i mustn't spend
too much time indulging myself i had a
bit of
a clock in my head when i was doing
coverage on myself i feel the
responsibility to nurture
the other actors and their performances
really and that's one of the
pleasures actually grand budapest hotel
i'd met wes a couple of times he'd been
extremely friendly to me and supportive
i had shown him
an early mood reel
or what they called the sizzle reel of
cory elena's when i was trying to make
it and get funding he had been very
supportive and
encouraging about it as an idea but that
was in a social situation
so some years later now you know um
three or four years later he's sending
me this script and he had a
eccentric approach which would say
please read the script and tell me which
character you'd like to play
well i think this one maybe
that was a very happy experience with
the way west works with
his ensemble of actors edward norton
william defoe and i think everyone
is there because they love the spirit of
his films
many of the hotel's most valued and
distinguished guests
came for him i love you i love you she
was dynamite in the sack by the way
she was 84. i've had older i remember
definitely thinking of who
who who do i know that are monsieur
gustav
like and then there is actually
he's supposedly based on a mutual
acquaintance
that i know west knows who
[Music]
came to the set and and i knew i don't i
don't mimic him
but i suppose i'm aware of this person's
energy and demeanor that i've taken it
on board
sunshine sunshine is directed by a great
hungarian direct ishvan sabo
and uh ishtavan asked me to be in this
film which is a story of a jewish
family's assimilation
in the 20th century in budapest in
hungary ishvan sabo said to me this film
is about the disease of wanting to be
accepted
who are you trying to please i have to
please our family and the memory of our
rabbi grandfather
i have to please the government and its
opposition i have to please our brother
who wants to turn the world upside down
and our father who wants to keep the
world exactly as it is
you play multiple characters i do i play
three there was differences in facial
hair and haircut i think
but i thought no that shouldn't be if
the film the storytelling
in the filmmaking is clear enough the
audience
will know it didn't seem at all the sort
of film where
the actor completely changes and oh my
god is it really him
her whatever it was no no you meant to
know it's me
you're meant to understand that you know
it's the same family it's the
the fact that i'm playing all three was
the linking element
the white chrome white crow is
about the um defection of rudolph nuria
for the events
leading up to his defection so this
great
russian ballet dancer who was arguably
like a sort of
equivalent to a pop star in the world of
ballet and
i grew up with i was never saw him dance
but i grew up with
his name being mentioned as the god of
ballet or
of male ballet dancers i was given the
um early chapters of a
new biography about nurif and when i
read about him
and it wasn't because i might had i love
a ballet it was because of his spirit
and that's what drew me to him very
confrontational
it's very often very difficult and and
abrasive and arguably abusive to people
and i found it very moving story and i
talked to the right screenwriter david
hare
who you will know from films like the
hours and the reader that i did
and david responded to the idea of
writing
so we worked together on that i learned
from the first film corey elena's
to not to be afraid afraid of getting a
lot of coverage
to take time to go for a few more takes
if i needed to even if it meant pushing
the overtime button a bit there's a
japanese director called ozu who has his
very simple
classic frames and he's probably very
unfashionable when i love films that
where the camera moves but but the
principle of
the frame that can behold the characters
or close-up on white crow we had three
time frames
so i i that principle of the sort of
classic frame in
the camera that either moves on a track
or was
locked off it was was applicable to the
leningrad
time frames where rudolph nirif is a
student
[Music]
when he's in paris it's more immediate
so then with mike ely the
brilliant cinematographer who shot that
we
a lot of it's in the hand so it's caught
moments or found and the camera
has permission to be a bit messy as it
looks for
the best way to discover a scene between
characters
my name is rudolf i want political
asylum no
did you have different cinematographers
for each section of the
film i did my three cinematographers
barry aykroyd rob hardy
mike ely all brilliant shooting ballet
which was
way out of my comfort zone i wanted an
unknown
to play in urea and i wanted to dance to
play nirif
because but it was principally an acting
part so persuading people to cast
a total unknown he's not even on not
even an actor by training
in the lead that was really difficult
this was never a film about his dance
career it was always
about what it is in the person i suppose
in an artist or a performer that
makes them determine to go there and and
often necessarily ruthless in their
pursuit of
excellence a bigger splash
harry hawks is the character our great
script by david kaganich luca guadagnino
directed
myself tilda swinton who plays
um a rock star with whom i have been in
love
she's with her current boyfriend matish
played by matthias schoenitz and
and set on an island called pantalaria
and we shot on the real pantalaria which
is an island between
sicily and tunisia but i love this park
this sort of
he's a music producer of a certain type
quite mouthy
and in your face um was there anyone
from your life that you
use this inspiration for harry
a little bit my brother magnus who was a
music producer and composer but a little
bit of magnus
but also justin leapt off the page about
who harry was
yeah and i just loved luca's approach
and when i first met luca and he talked
about it and the part was great
on the page and i just like luca's
filmic intelligence and his inquiry and
uh he he's properly creative on a set
and
i just love he thinks very beautifully
filmically
he respects the journey of the
characters whilst i mean there are some
filmmakers who you can their direction
sort of smothers
the life of characters with fancy camera
work or funny editing choices or
the english patient on the english
patient
we all meaning the actors with anthony
and the crew we all believed in the
emotional sort of breadth and scope of
it it all felt
like a drama that had
visual scope and emotional scope and but
at the time i mean it was hard to
finance because none of the protagonists
were
in the eyes of the hollywood
establishment none of us were
insurance stars we were all
up-and-comers
so it didn't jump out at the people with
the purses
it was in fact harvey weinstein who
saved it
but through miramax he came in and and
saved it because it was
it was going down just before we were
due to start i have a happy memory of
being in great locations in being in
rome for a while and going to tuscany
then going to venice for a short time
then going to tunisia
going to the sahara so suddenly in this
desert landscape clifton
offered to fly down from cairo to
collect me
he flew like a madman always so i
i don't think now with the way
independent films or that sort of adult
drama
character-led films the sort of budget
would be hard now you'd
probably have to shoot in half the time
we shot from september to january
19 1995 to january 96
the constant gardener it's a john le
carre
story um produced by simon channing
williams who i talked about earlier
who came to me with the project simon
brought in um fernando morelos who was
very
that he was being talked about for the
city of god
and i thought that was an inspired
choice because
there's a kind of englishness that
sits with john the carrier's work which
is great
i could see how an english director
would confirm
certain stereotypes i mean the whole
thing was had the looseness and the
documentary-like feel
which um shook it and i think shook it
away from the pages of
of a book which is what i think you need
that
how are you how are you we can't involve
ourselves in their lives tess
there are millions of people they all
need help justin quail his name
he's a certain type of self-effacing
englishman of a certain sort of middle
class
miss i suppose well-mannered charming
possibly thought of as ineffectual
and um you know not someone to shoulder
their way to the front of a cube not
someone who
pushes forward their ambition but is
decent and
reveals himself to have a core of steel
and determination in trying
to avenge or get to this at least to the
the secret of his wife's murder
the appeal to me was here as a guy that
everyone thinks is
a bit soft actually has a kind of
extraordinary courage and i love that
movement you know this is someone who no
one thinks
but he pursues and pursues and pursues
and pursues i'm not conscious that i
have the same approach for every
part because often the director you're
working with informs the approach you
might take a lot of the time i
feel things intuitively i think about
who they are i think about their inner
life where are they from who their
parents what you know
you can give yourself imagination
exercises
people ask about research but actually
there is research but actually a lot of
it i think is
just intuit intuition and imagination